i cannot believe we have to do a show
today guys this is seriously a freaking
nightmare like this is an absolute
nightmare cali's freaking destroyed
oh it's just
but we'll do it we got a job to do right
like no matter what we got a job to do
so
this is the good stuff by the way don
julio you know the don julio
yeah let me just i cannot believe i have
to tell people that there's hope you
know
it's just going to be a terrible day
what we're live we're live we're live um
hey hi
how are you
uh
it's uh september 15th
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message it's the day after
it's the day after
yesterday and here we are uh there was
the big
recall election and uh hold on just a
sec as long as long as they know my deep
dark secret you know
it's like
we got a show to do you know what i'm
saying like
everything's gonna be okay callie you
guys are gonna be all right you're gonna
be all right um
okay guys so we have a bunch to talk
about uh we're not doing
regular stories today um i have no notes
in front of me we did not pick stories i
don't feel like doing any other current
events
um we've got a little video that we're
going to throw to
as i'm talking um but um
this can be a little different today
because obviously today is not a great
day if you're a californian and it's not
a great day if you're an american and
it's not a great day if you're just a
decent freedom loving person right it's
just not a great day so that's number
one so i'm not gonna sit here and
pretend that like i'm in the greatest
mood ever or that i think everything's
great and i'm not going to promise you
that things will get better because i
can't promise you that like i just can't
um however i first want to say
something just about my experience in
this whole recall election
and what's happened to this country and
this state in the last year and a half
and everything else you know i woke up
this morning
and
although i sort of like at first i was
just like
what am i going to do on the show what
am i going to do i got to tell you that
in the you know four
five hours i got up at about 7 a.m the
four or five hours that i've been awake
i'm actually feeling quite proud today
like i really do feel
that in the last year and a half i have
fought for what i believe in at the
highest possible level i have done
everything that i could possibly do to
make this recall happen to get rid of a
guy that i think is a really terrible
governor who is destroying this state
and i don't have to repeat all the
reasons why i think he is you guys all
know that um but more importantly than
that when when larry elder got involved
in this thing and there were rumblings
you know there were rumblings that maybe
dennis prager was going to get involved
there were rumblings that adam carolla
was going to get involved there were
rumblings that rick grinnell was going
to get involved i i strongly considered
it for a couple weeks i really did and
we we talked to some people
um
and i just felt that i would be more
useful outside of of the system than
than the guy that was doing it you know
i could help with messaging and
amplification and all that kind of stuff
but when larry got involved i felt that
this was
basically as good as it gets like this
is
not just a good and decent man and as
you know i don't care about the color of
his skin
um but for the people that do i thought
it could help flip the script a little
bit
and expose the nonsense of the left and
although larry did lose
and the recall lost i think we've really
exposed further just the absolute
fraudulent dishonest nature of the media
and the democratic establishment and our
political leaders and everything else
but i felt i would give this thing
everything i've gotten i toured with
larry and obviously i've been promoting
the hell out of him on twitter and on
the show and every other which way and i
introduced him to some some money people
and people that i thought could help i
gave this everything i got and when i
say i also want to give a shout out to
the two guys that are in this room
michael and connor who have helped me
along the way do all this stuff and and
my assistant helen and and talia and
everybody that's part of this team and
david ev everyone that's part of my team
here like we all were like there's
something to fight for let's fight for
it together and we all did everything
that we could possibly do so
again i'm not sitting here like oh this
is the greatest day and there's so many
like look on the horizon like things
will get better i'm not really sure how
i feel about that here in california
right now actually i think things are
going to get a lot worse i think they
have the the bad
forces and the forces that i've been
fighting against
that i believe to be the wrong ideas
like they're strengthened in california
right now and california is obviously
the you know it's the biggest state in
the union and it is one of the biggest
economies in the world and everything
else like the bad ideas of critical race
theory and social justice and
mismanagement of everything in high
taxes and high regulation all that stuff
like it all just got strengthened that's
just the truth like it got emboldened
and
lord only knows what all of that garbage
stuff does when it's emboldened probably
some bad stuff
but what sits next to that for me is
that i i feel like i i personally did
what i felt was right and there's value
in that so it's not you don't win all
the time you don't and especially in
politics you don't win and you know i
say to you guys all the time that one of
the biggest problems that we have in
america right now is that people have
traded religion or belief just any sort
of traditional set of beliefs
for politics right and i think it
there's a particularly pernicious
version of this with
people on the left because they have so
accepted the purely secular world view
that they feel like because they don't
believe in something else they believe
that they
have the duty or the responsibility
or the divine right even though they
usually don't believe in the divine to
organize the world as they see fit and
in many ways that's really what this
election was about like a guy like gavin
newsom who thinks he should wield power
over people and if you just gave him
enough money and power he could figure
out how more people could live or should
live
and versus the ideas that larry elder
was bringing to the table the things
that i talk about which are
that the government's really not that
good at a lot of stuff and
it shouldn't take from a lot of people
it shouldn't do that much there's some
basic stuff that it should do and that's
it but
those ideas didn't work this time around
and and yes maybe there was some fraud
and we all know that if you i mean blake
masters who's running for
uh senate in arizona who i think is
really good guy who i'm going to have on
the show in a couple weeks he he tweeted
out an image where if you just take a
basic
iphone
flashlight
to a ballot
you could automatically see the yes and
the vote for larry
we checked it no matter which way you
folded the envelope even though i voted
in person we tested it on on our mailing
ballot no matter which way you folded it
either you could see the yes or you
could see larry i'm not saying there was
fraud i'm actually not even though i
think the system here is deeply corrupt
like i don't i i'm not saying there's
fraud and i have no evidence there was
fraud but i know that the system here is
just broken it is a one-party system and
lord only knows what these people would
do but i'm not i'm not going down that
rabbit hole um
but what i'm saying is that if a certain
amount of people don't have faith in the
system and that's what i'm hearing from
a lot of people you know i went to a
election night party last night at
pineapple hill grill and saloon you may
remember pineapple hill there was the
incredible viral video from the height
of the lockdowns where um
the the woman who owns it angela was a
great great lady
she was there last night obviously
she had taken some video where she built
this outdoor
area for people to come and sit so that
she could keep her restaurant open at
the height of the lockdowns and they
locked her down but then they had a huge
outdoor eating area for a hollywood
shoot literally steps away right next
door that video got seen millions and
millions and millions of times so we
thought that that would be the place to
do our little election situation last
night and you know about 100 people
showed up
maybe more actually and it was these
were all good people i didn't meet any
racists or right-wing maniacs um i
didn't meet any
bad people
you know like and by the way i'm not
even sure how many republicans i met
most of the people were sort of mugged
liberals as i talk about or independents
or just apolitical people and some of
them were i would say more conservative
but you're not going to believe this
guys there were gay people there and
there were black people there and they
were asian people and latino people they
were all there and they were all there
not because we all agree on politics i
mean that's the interesting thing nobody
really talked about politics there last
night like everyone kind of talked about
oh we just kind of want to be left alone
we don't like this slow descent to hell
that this state is on
and we support larry and actually i was
able to get larry to call in and i went
up to uh the microphone and larry we
took the phone call and larry said hi to
everybody and it was great
and and i guess i say all of this to say
i don't regret anything here right now
like i don't think politics is
everything like
i don't think and that's why they're so
hysterical and we're usually not so
that's not to say i'm not dejected today
i'm not thrilled with the day i have to
really think about a lot of things in my
life and uh you know talk to my team
about the future and what we want to do
about cali and
all of that stuff like that's all legit
right but like
i fought for something
and fighting for something is a
worthwhile cause believing in something
is a worthwhile cause doing something
going against the grain standing up
against the machine i see these all as
good things and these are things that i
did so i feel
and again not just me the people around
me that we all did so i feel a great
sense of pride right now and i hope you
feel that too and even last night you
know it was interesting because eight
o'clock is when the polls roll uh closed
but basically at 801 they announced it
was pretty much like it's over already
because of all the mail in ballots that
they had already come in so they were
pulling it they were you know showing
you polls that it was like 70 30
basically at you know no on the recall
basically at 805 something like that and
you know everyone in that room it was
like we all knew it was a long shot
everyone in that room so when we got
there at like five o'clock and
everyone's having drinks and eating
wings and burgers and stuff it's like
we're all having a great time but of
course it was sitting in the back of our
head i knew it this whole time like
there's more democrats than republicans
it's a democrat run state all of that
stuff like you know as i always say i'm
a dreamer
but i'm not just like a blind dreamer
like we knew this was going to be tough
and you know by 805 when when uh
it ended or in essence it ended um
nobody was crying in that room people
kept talking kept having a good time we
all kind of were nodding at each other
like you know this sucks and we we got
to think about
our lives and what we want to do and do
we want to be here and all of those
things but i was very proud to be in
that room with those people
and i think that's the feeling that if
you watch this show and you care about
the ideas that i talk about and you you
love a guy like larry elder and you
believe in the types of things that he
talks about like that's what we should
take with us
what you do in your life especially if
you live in california that's up to you
like do you stay and fight i don't see
much hope in staying and fighting here i
think it's going to get much worse
there's just no reason to think it won't
um do you go do you finally go and you
all know that at the height of the
lockdowns when everything was locked
down i had an illegal dinner party
i'm sure they'll come for me one day i
had uh right wing maniac michael knowles
from the daily wire and his wife over
we all lived in cali at the time we all
lived in la they came over for dinner at
the height of the lockdowns this is like
april or something when you weren't
supposed to see people and mask up and
stay in your basement forever and
michael and i uh over some whiskey
decided to stay and fight it was just
when there were some rumblings about a
recall and i said i'm going to give this
thing everything i got and knowles
agreed knowles was like we're going to
stay we're going to fight we're going to
do it we toasted to whiskey i was like
this is great we'll get ben to stay
and and the next morning the daily wire
announced that they were moving to
nashville and knolls was god i don't say
that as a shot to nulls i actually love
nulls and i think he's a great
political thinker and a great guy he
didn't know that they were about to
announce that they were leaving
but i did what i said i was going to do
a year and a half ago i stayed and i
fought you know like i fought for what i
believe in there's no shame in that
there just isn't so i feel oddly good
today it's hard to explain like i'm sort
of depressed about the general state of
the world but i feel like i did
something decent in the midst of that
and that's pretty good and i want to
talk a little bit about about larry and
we'll we'll throw up some old larry
footage while i'm talking about larry
because the video that we're going to
show you a little b-roll right now is uh
the first time that i sat down with
larry elder and i think that was in can
we confirm this i think that was in
about february of 2016 am i right
uh 2015. no no i think it was 2016.
i'm 99 sure it was 2016. but that's a
long time ago that's you know it's over
five years ago five and a half years ago
and i was a lefty at the time and
there's larry elder and i said something
about systemic racism and that man beat
me senseless with facts he beat me
senseless with facts uh it was january
2016. i was off by a couple weeks okay
that's fine
and my life changed at that moment i
know that you've all seen that clip but
my life absolutely changed in that
moment i was already struggling with so
much of the rhetoric of the left
and thinking that everyone was racist
and everyone was a homophobe and all of
the nonsense and the identity politics
stuff it was all
like it was all just like slamming me at
once and i was waking up right and
you've all been through this i have no
doubt that everyone that watching this
one way or another whether you've been a
conservative for 20 years whether you're
a liberal waking up now whether these
terms mean nothing anymore and you're
just some human trying to piece together
something that makes sense we all have
our wake up moments right and that
moment with larry let's throw it back
again we're going to show you the same
clip again while i'm talking but it was
just you've all seen it i know you've
seen it it's been seen 30 probably a
million times across all the different
youtube and everywhere else
and
and he beat me with facts but did it
with grace and decency and when the show
ended
i know many of you know the story but we
shook hands we said we'll do the show
again i think he realized that he was
sitting across from somebody that was
willing to learn and willing to listen
and um you know it was my best and worst
career moment at the exact same time
at the exact same time because i went
into what turned into a debate and i
wasn't ready i thought well if you just
say systemic racism exists it does
because that's what the left does with
everything there should be 15 minimum
wage because we think there should be we
should do this america is evil because
of this 1619 project's true because we
say it's true this is what the left does
with absolutely everything and larry had
facts well this is what police shootings
are this is what affirmative action has
done this is what the ever expanding
state has has done uh to black and brown
communities et cetera et cetera it
wasn't not that the whole interview was
just about that stuff but i went back
into that control room and there were a
bunch of producers there this is when we
were on aura tv we had a bigger staff
at the time and you know that that
interview did not air live we taped it
live and then it was going to air the
next day and everybody everyone in that
room said dave don't worry we're going
to cut that part we're going to cut that
part and i don't know where it came from
within me but i said no we're not going
to if i'm an interviewer if anything
that i do is true and real well i get it
i get it i don't look so great right
there but we have to air that as is and
that's what we did and you know the next
day or two or three as the video started
getting copied and then it was like you
know black conservative destroys libtard
and like all the other versions of that
that get cut across youtube and i
started seeing millions of views and i
was like oh you know this is not my best
moment but i started looking in the
comments and people were going boy dave
seems like he listened
this is just the beginning of something
and it was the beginning of something it
was the beginning of something that then
led me talking to dennis prager and
having a conversation with ben shapiro
and talking to glenn beck and eventually
finding jordan peterson and and the rest
of all of this that you now know about
me over the last couple years and about
my political evolution and all of those
things
and i think the reason that people watch
what i do is because i've been honest
about
the whole thing you know like you've
seen it on camera you've seen it unfold
on camera
um
and you know even just a month ago we
had larry in here right and this is now
in our new studio and can i say i'm
aging pretty decently uh not bad right
like for five years pretty good
um but but he sat in this room in my
house
not only as a friend
and as a candidate but as a mentor and
someone that i respect who is a decent
guy who again didn't want to get into
this thing
didn't want to get in so that he could
tell everybody how to live but he felt
it was a calling
um i don't even know if larry would want
me to say this but you know his his
girlfriend nina who we've become good
friends with too who's great she kind of
pushed him more than he was pushing
himself larry's got a great life he's
had this great radio show he he does all
sorts of appearances and talks and
everything else like he didn't need this
but i know when i was out on the road uh
with him just in the last two weeks we
were in thousand oaks i think we got
some video of that too
and and i was campaigning for him and
there were about a thousand people there
it was probably a hundred degrees at
least this was at 2 p.m the middle of
the day in l.a it was hot as hell
and and to meet all of those people out
there and i'm telling you these were not
racist people these were not
bad people these were not evil trump
supporters or whatever the meme is that
that they say about all of us i know
what the truth is
and i know that that truth
is not lined up with what mainstream
media tells you i know that that truth
is not lined up with what
big tech allows you to see and i really
know after this these last couple weeks
that that truth is not not that true the
truth is not lined up with the way
democratic politicians are talking about
things so when joe biden dares come here
two days ago
and says that larry elder is a trump
clone and refuses to say his name
i thought it was say his name say her
name wasn't that a thing when uh when
when a black person is shot say her name
say his name well they committed an
assassination of larry elder here a a a
career assassination a reputation
assassination joe biden refused to say
larry elder's name as he's calling him a
clone of trump a trump clone larry elder
who was born in south central l.a larry
elder whose dad was a janitor larry
elder who went from nothing and because
of capitalism and america became
something and became someone who now
millions of people will learn the right
ideas by how is he treated by joe biden
and the democrats barack obama who put
out an ad attacking larry elder but
would not say his name
gavin newsom who maybe said his name
once or twice but repeatedly lied about
him
lied about him and then had the gaul
this evil cartoon villain had the gall
last night to say this is a win for
diversity that's what he said this is a
win
for diversity can you pull uh i'm not
even going to bother with the avenue
it's not important he has nothing to do
with my life
not much longer
so
all of that being said um
i can't sit here and lie to you
i can't sit here and lie to you and say
guys you know
this is a disaster but from this
disaster like more and more people will
wake up and things will get better in
this state i'm really not sure i live
here
you know i go to these places and i see
brainwashed masked people who are afraid
of their own shadow and it's not
everybody i meet so many good people
here too and that that's sort of been
the fuel for all of this i would say
more than anything else my the locals
community has been the fuel because
that's where i i talk to you guys and i
see what you're thinking even if i can't
respond to every little thing
but there's no bots and trolls so i get
to communicate and i get to
like feel the zeitgeist of the people
that i care about right so like that
fuels me but then when i go out and
about here and people say nice things to
me or people say things on it on the
airplane or whatever and we're all kind
of outsiders in the system right like
we're not the insiders and that's the
irony you know the the progressives are
always running around screaming that
they're the resistance and it's like no
you're not it's like that aoc video from
yesterday at the 30 000 met gala
pretending she's fighting the power and
she is the power
and
i will keep fighting for these ideas
i may not be fighting for these ideas
from california for much longer
but i will keep fighting for these ideas
and i will keep fighting for this
country
and and i hope that any of you who are
like a little upset about the way this
turned out right like
if you're upset about the way this
turned out there's something that you
can do
in your life to fight against
this this oncoming horror that we know
is happening in the united states we are
under attack we are under attack i don't
know exactly who it's from or how it's
happening exactly this confluence of
media and big tech i mean even if you
think about it this way you know i had
rose mcgowan on last week she talks
about how jennifer newsom gavin's wife
approached her on behalf of harvey
weinstein's lawyer to see how the story
could go away
imagine if that was ted cruz what the
media would have done with that if it
was ted cruz's wife
the media is evil
they're evil so we are fighting the
media and we are fighting big tech and
does that make me a conspiracy theorist
or alex jones
i don't think so i don't think you think
so but we got work to do and i and i
hate to tell you that if you think
that you know ducking your head you know
doing the ostrich head in the sand thing
is gonna work if you think just being
the frog in the pot is gonna work as the
temperature rises like it doesn't work
out well for the frog and there's a lot
of beheaded ostriches okay so before we
get to the beheading phase of this thing
it's like figure it out
for yourself and as i say that to you i
mean it for me too like we have a lot of
things to figure out around here right
like david and i have a great life here
we've got great friends we throw great
parties we eat great food i've got great
employees
i have
literally there's no physical thing that
i want
on this earth there really isn't we go
on good vacations like i don't have i
don't want anything i don't flip through
amazon like oh i want to buy that or
that like i have the things that i want
what i don't have right now
is the comfort of living in a state that
i think has a future
that's a weird thing right like that
that's kind of weird
and and and the truth is
i thought i i've thought for a long time
probably since covid began that america
was entering this sort of cold civil war
situation but it's here it really is
here like the stark differences between
the blue and the red are so obvious now
critical race theory
social justice
taxes regulation
all of the coveted mandates like it's
all here we are splitting
i don't you know i try not to alarm you
guys i mean that's the thing i think if
i do anything on this show it's that i
try not to alarm you i'm i'm trying not
to enrage you right
but and for a year i didn't even want to
say that i was thinking it and i didn't
want to say it because it's like i don't
want to add fuel to that but but here we
are
if you live in california you live under
a vastly different
set of rules and and laws than you do in
florida
and that chasm is going to continue to
get wider and wider and by the way
that's not necessarily depressing the
idea of a cold civil war is depressing
but the idea that states can make
decisions for themselves and then you
still have an opportunity to do that
foot vote thing say no i'm not going to
live here i'm going to take my skills
and my family and my my values and i'm
going to strengthen another place
you got a chance you got a chance in
america most places don't have that most
countries don't have that federalist
system that let you allow that allow you
to live in different places with
drastically different laws and
lifestyles and all of those things
um
but i can tell you you know it's like
cali's not turning around anytime soon
so if you're i met a lot of people last
night and a lot of community members
that i know that i've met before and
everyone had that look that look of just
like
all right maybe it's up maybe it's up
now i've had everyone said it i've got
all my friends are leaving
we know california had its first net
loss of population so it's like maybe we
should just leave right and it's like if
i left i know a bunch of other people
would be coming with me and i pay a hell
of a lot in taxes
quite a disturbing amount actually
to fund the pet projects of these
maniacs
for projects that don't do anything that
projects that just make everything worse
if the high taxes worked then why is
there all the homelessness if the high
taxes worked then why do the roads all
suck if the high taxes worked then why
don't more people have jobs and then
house prices maybe would drop because
more people would afford house houses
and then competition would kick in but
none of it works so it's like
these are all the things that i got to
think about and that i'm sure millions
of others are thinking about um but
again i hope you feel if if you did what
you thought was right in this thing and
if you shared a video and you told
anyone about this recall and and
hopefully larry elder you know one of
the reasons that i think that they
purposely didn't say his name
is they don't want you to google larry
elder you know i i really mean that i
know that might sound a little nuts but
one i mean joe biden disgusting it's
actually disgusting
we
forget everything else that i've said
here there was a black man was the
leading candidate to replace gavin
newsom in the largest state in the
united states of america and these
people who tell us we're all racists
refuse to say his name
they're awful they're awful if you
looked at the media hits you know we
played the thing yesterday if you
googled larry elder's name just hit
piece after hit piece after hit piece
after hit piece so that's what we're up
against
but david beat goliath
and i'm david
uh all right that's that's my thoughts
for today i got a couple media hits
today um obviously this stuff ain't
going anywhere um tonight actually is
this begins the holiest day in the in
the jewish year it's yom kippur which
goes all the way into tomorrow i will be
fasting and doing the temple thing so
we're pre-taping tomorrow's q a uh today
so if you'd like to submit a question
we're going to be taping it about an
hour you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com
and for anyone that's observing the
holiday i wish you an easy fast as they
say a lot of hungry jews in a room it
can it can be quite intense uh and then
friday uh we're doing a panel show it's
gonna be all about canada you know
canada has elections coming up and there
are a couple decent
larry elder type people that are running
in canada so viva fry is running and
we're going to have him and we're going
to have ezra levant and we're working on
getting maxine bernier from the uh
people's party um but he's having a
little we're trying to arrange something
but he's got a flight
anyway we'll have a great show all about
canada because i want to i want to help
spread these ideas in canada too um
anyway i have a feeling i'll be chatting
more with people in the locals community
today if you want to if you want to get
me and and i hope more than anything
else like even though this was sort of
somber this wasn't like the usual thing
that i do um
there's there's reason to feel good
because in this country at least for now
you still have some choice to figure out
how you want to live
and again i as i say that to you i'm
saying it to myself so
it's decision time it's decision time uh
have a great day everybody and uh i'll
see you on friday